[Music]
when we were working with Destin and his
high-speed camera we tried one of our
favorite experiments Neil's burning
cauldron
now the demonstration consists of two
parts the first one is taking a metal
vessel and pouring in liquid oxygen when
you watch it normally it's just pouring
stuff out of a thermos flask what's
interesting in high-speed is that as it
goes in the oxygen actually breaks up
[Music]
there's been a lot of research by
different people about how liquids fall
and it's quite complicated because it's
a combination of surface tension
viscosity but here you have the added
complication that the liquid is very
cold compared to the air so it's
actually boiling when it goes in there's
a salt cloudiness but that's just the
water vapor in the air you end up with a
rather foggy looking liquid
the second part of the experiment is
dropping in a piece of hot charcoal the
first thing that quite surprised me is
that as this piece of charcoal comes
down and hits the surface it actually
bounces up again but because it bounces
up again and presumably the hot charcoal
has vaporized a bit more oxygen it
actually starts burning when it's in the
air and as it comes down again
it burns quite bright thing
[Music]
I'll think about it for moments you've
got a very hot piece of charcoal on top
of a very cold liquid so the liquid
immediately under the charcoal will be
boiling and will be generating gas which
probably causes the charcoal almost to
float above the surface of the liquid
and if you look carefully you can see
that the charcoal keeps on burning
brightly and then it goes dimmer again
and then bright and dim a sort of
pulsing and I think and again I haven't
done any control experiments but it
seems quite likely that what happens is
that when it's sitting on oxygen gas
it burns rather more brightly it uses up
that gas and then sinks down onto the
surface of the liquid the hot charcoal
vaporizes some more and it starts
burning again lifted up on the oxygen
cloud so it goes up and down but the key
point is that I as a chemist see that
something that I thought was fairly
straightforward is actually more
interesting and more complicated than I
thought not to inflame things or try
make too much of the chemistry physics
rivalry but it seems like in some of
these talks we have it's like the
chemistry's well understood but it's the
physics that's really interesting and
adding this extra dimension when we see
it at high speed I think that's a very
sensible point because very often in the
short term on short timescales it is the
physics the mixing of the reaction or
the viscosity or whatever that
determines what happens
and you could argue that it's really
chemical engineering rather than physics
but it is this combination of the
chemical process and the physical one
that is very interesting it is important
because many of the phenomena we observe
even when we're looking slowly is a
result of these two effects but we don't
always realize they're going on
[Laughter]